bien mes chers collègues nous allons
débuter notre
audition voilà on va se reconcentrer
après avoir une un pe petite pause
photographique voilà donc nous
accueillons à présent monsieur hard donc
directeur général de l'Agence centrale
des organismes de sécurité sociale
désormais connu sous le nom de URSAF
caisse nationale donc nous allons bien
entendu aborder le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
j'indique également que cette audition
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et disponible bien entendu à la
demande monsieur le directeur général je
vais vous donner la parole afin que vous
nous présentiez à la fois l'avis du
conseil d'administration de l'Agence sur
le le projet de budget mais vous pourrez
aussi nous décrire l'évolution de la
situation financière entre la poursuite
de l'accumulation de déficit de
plusieurs branches les transferts de
déficit à la cadèe et qui vont
d'ailleurs bientôt s'achever et surtout
ce qui nous préoccupe beaucoup c'est des
tensions observées sur le marché des
taux voilà donc ensuite les membres de
la commission et en premier lieu notre
rapporteur général Élisabeth douanau
vous poseront un certain nombre de
questions vous connaissez l'exercice
voilà c'est le directeur c'est à
vous merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président alors concernant euh l'avis du
conseil d'administration effectivement
euh de laass nationale il a été
majoritairement défavorable comme dans
les autres euh conseil d'administration
alors il y a plusieurs éléments qui ont
pu Motier ce positionnement et qui sont
différents sur les organisations
syndicales et patronal bien entendu je
pense qu'il faut mentionner euh par
exemple dans les motifs d'opposition de
certaines organisations notamment
l'absence dans le texte initial de la
réforme de la S des travailleurs
indépendants
attendu par les organisations présent
travailleur indépendant CPME et up au
premier rang et qui du coup a motivé le
vote contre de ces deux
organisations ah alors il faut que je me
rapproche ou ah oui étimement c'est
mieux oui c'est c'est beaucoup mieux je
vous prie de m'excuser oui donc pour
résumer ce que je disais le conseil
d'administration paritaire de de l'URSAF
adopté un avis défavorable contre le
pfss comme le l'ensemble des caisses
nationales alors avec des motifs
différents selon les organisations bien
entendu mais dans les motifs
d'opposition peut relever il y avait par
exemple s'agissant de la CPME et de
l'UDP l'absence de réforme de l'assiette
social des travailleurs indépendants qui
est un sujet fortement attendu par ces
organisations qui avaient été évoqué
d'ailleurs dans le cadre général de la
réforme des retraites euh alors après
concernant effectivement
euh le les fait marquant financier de
cette année 2000 2023 avec un petit pont
sur 2024
cette année est marqué par un retour à
situation qu'on av pas connu depuis très
longtemps c'est-à-dire que on on a une
trésorerie moyenne de régime général qui
est proche de l'équilibre en moyenne sur
l'année on a un solde moyen de 1,9
milliards et on va même finir l'année
côté régime général avec un solde
positif de 4,5 milliards alors c'est le
résultat principalement d'une réduction
du du déficit et puis effectivement
d'unun reprise massive de dett par la
cadè à hauteur de 27,3 milliards donc
effectivement c'est
le alors effectivement désolé je un peu
vite je peêre un petit peu vite oui mais
vous vous faites bien de me le dire sur
l'année en moyenne le solde du régime
général donc la sitation de trésorerie
moyenne du régime général sur l'année
c'est - 1,9 milliards et alors
concrètement sur l'année on a commence
l'année 2023 avec un besoin de
financement important et on finit
l'année avec finalement un sold positif
de trésorie çaut dire qu'on a des
disponibilités en trésorerie à hauteur
de 4,5 milliards en fin d'année alors
c'est principalement le résultat d'une
reprise de dett par la cadè qui a été à
hauteur de 27,3 milliards et qui fait
qu'effectivement on s'éloigne des
montants très élevé de dettte porté par
la cause au plus fort de la crise
sanitaire et même je crois que ça fait
quand même très longtemp qu'on avait pas
connu cette situation positive de
trésorerie au régime
général alors après il y a quand même
deux tempéraments à cela qui expliquent
qu'on continue bien entendu à
recourir TR d'ailleurs quiourir à des
besoins de financement sur les marchés
c'est que bah les notre sitation de
trésorerie elle évolue chaque jour en
fonction des dates de paiement des
prestations notamment des retraites des
prestations CAF des encassements des
cotisations donc
selon les moments de l'année ça évolue
il y a aussi par ailleurs un élément
important et qui va peser dans les
années qui viennent aussi sur les
besoins de financement d'émission de
financement de la cause c'est les
avances que la cause fait un certain
nombre de régimes
autrees des régimes donc pour lesquels
la Cuse empreinte sur les marchés pour
leur faire des avances on a c'est un
choix qui a été retenu de manière
générale car on considérait que la Cuse
réussirait à obtenir de meilleures
conditions financires
pour s'endetter que ces petits régimes
et donc effectivement de plusieurs
années que la COS va sur les marchés
pour emprunter et faire des avances à
ces régimes le régime qui est le plus
concerné par ces avances c'est la CaCl
donc la caisse de retraite des
fonctionnaires hospitaliers et
territoriaux qui a une trajectoire
financière très dégradée et qui continue
à se dégrader et qui du coup nous nous
conduit à emprunter pour pour pouvoir
leur prêter et puis par ailleurs un
autre point c'est que depuis la crise
sanitaire considérant que on estement
entr dans un monde plus risqué où il
peut survenir des chocs assez
imprévisibles mais qui à un moment
peuvent perturber le fonctionnement de
l'économie ou des marchés financiers de
ce fait nous donnons comme objectif
d'avoir toujours une trésorerie pour
couvrir le mois le mois qui les 30 jours
devant nous pour
pouvoir justement faire face à une
situation où nos rentrées seraiit frappé
comme on l'a connu en mars 2020 ou là
aussi qu' a connu en mars 2020 par une
situation
où on ne pourrait pas aller sur les
marchés pendant de 3 semaines et donc on
a on a un suremprunt de 15 milliards en
fait qui est une poche d'emprunt qu'on
réalise au-delà du strict besoin de
financement mais pour avoir cette
possibilité de voir venir sur les 30
jours devant nous en cas de
choc de choc qui qui surviendrait alors
si one l'année 2024 on va garder ces
situation de trésorerie positive
jusqu'au mois de septembre et puis en
fin d'année on sera de nouveau pour le
régime général en situation de trésorie
négative parce que on va porter le
déficit 2024 régime général reste
déficit en 2024 et puis effectivement on
portera toujours le déficit de la cén cl
à hauteur de 10 milliards donc ce qui
explique que le plafond d'emprunt
proposé dans le PS 2024 reste au niveau
de
euh de celui de 2023 à savoir 45
milliards
c'est assez nettement au-dessus de ce
qu'on pense être notre creux de
trésorerie de l'année qui constiue à 34
milliards mais depuis justement a de la
crise sanitaire on a fait le choix
d'avoir des des
plafonds de de dett à cause qui soitent
calé acune marge de sécurité en cas
d'événements là aussi qui peuvent à un
moment survenir et affecter l'économie
on a quand même passé l'anne 2023 à
craindre des chocs sur l'activité du
fait de l'environnement international de
de l'inflation de la crise énergétique
bon pour le moment l'emploi et la masse
AR ont plutôt bien résisté mais voilà on
sait qu'on est exposé à ce type de
risque donc ce qui conduit à proposer
euh
ces
c'est ce plafond
inchangé vous avez posé la question
effectivement de l'évolution des taux
d'intérêt alors c'est vrai qu'on a vécu
pendant plusieurs années avec des taux
d'intérêt négatif
qui du coup sont devenus positif et même
très nettement positif alors ce qui
s'est passé c'est que dans le même temps
justement la dette du régime général a
très fortement
diminué et ce qui fait par exemple si
one sur l'année 2023 on pense que N nos
charges de dette seront de l'ordre de 50
millions parce que en fait on a eu une
première partie de l'année on avait
encore des taux négatif on
a des taux qui ont C augmenté au cours
de l'année mais comme en fin d'année
finalement on se retrouve de nouveau en
trésorerie positive cette trésorerie
elle rapporte et si on regarde l'année
[Musique]
2024 on pense qu'on devrait avoir pour
le coup des résultats financiers
positifs puisque donc on va faire une
partie de l'année en
étant avec une trésorerie positive euh
et donc là pour le coup un taux
d'environ 3 75 % bah nous permet
d'espérer 270 millions de produits
financiers pour le régime général en
2024 voilà pour donner quelques élément
un peu sur cette situation qui est quand
même très très différente de ce que
celle qu'on a connu il y a encore 2 ansù
on on était à la fois dans des niveaux
de dette record mais avec un
environnement de taux négatif qui fait
que cette dette très élevée finalement
nous rapportait donc là effectivement on
aurait pu être exposé à un risque
important avec la remontée des taux pour
le moment on une situation où grâce aux
repris de dett CADs on est revenu a une
bonne sitation de trésorerie fait que ça
ne ça ne coûte pas et même ça un peu
rapporté en
2024 bien entendu ça n'aura qu'un temps
puisque quand on le voit la trajectoire
de soldes plurannuel est quand même
effectivement dégradé et donc ça veut
dire que tout chose égal par ailleurs à
partir de 2025 on peut avoir des charges
de dettes qui redeviennent
significatives voà monsieur le Président
très bien Monsieur le Directeur je vais
donner la parole à Elisabeth
Wau merci monsieur le Président merci à
vous Monsieur le Directeur d'avoir lancé
les grandes lignes de cette audition je
je voudrais rappeler parce que nous
avons des des nouveaux collègues qui
sont ici et qui euh
évidemment commence à appréhender tous
ces termes et c'est vrai que on peut le
dire c'est tout de même un petit peu
barbare pour une première fois je
voudrais rappeler que l'acos parce que
souvent voilà on entend ces euh ces
diminutifs mais c'est pas toujours
facile de se dire mais qu'est-ce que la
cause par rapport à l'URSAF en fait la C
c'est l'Agence centrale des URSAF
c'est-à-dire de l'ensemble des
collecteurs et de ceux qui gèrent ces
cotisation et qui vont gérer la
redistribution en quelque sorte je
voulais le redire permettez-moi de faire
un petit peu
de de pédagogie parce que c'est ce n'est
pas évident vous avez indiqué et c'est
d'ailleurs le l'article liminaire de ce
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale la les prévisions de
dépenses de recettes et de soldes dans
ce comment article liminaire
effectivement il est rappelé que les
excédents de la
CADES qui qui correspond en fait à
l'amortissement j'explique en même temps
l'amortissement de de la dette des
régimes obligatoires de base de la
sécurité sociale et sont de 18,3
milliards d'euros euh en 2023 et ils ont
comme vous l'avez dit contribué
largement euh au solde positif justement
euh de ce secteur mes questions
désormais sur cette situation financière
la loi du du 7 août 2020 relative donc à
la dette sociale et à l'autonomie a
autorisé le transfert de 136 milliards
d'euros justement de l'URSAF Caisse
nationale de la à la Caisse nationale de
la cadesse de l'ursaave caisse nationale
de la cadesse il ressort des montants
déjà transférés qu'il n'est plus
possible de transférer désormais que il
me semble 8,8 milliards d'euros en
2024 si si en fait on peut se dire si
rien n'était fait les déficit
s'accumulerait à l'URSAF casse nationale
donc quelles sont les questions qui
découlent de cet état de fait d'abord
quel en cours maximal de dette l'URSAF
caisse nationale est
esttilelle pouvoir gérer dans de bonnes
conditions quelles seraient ensuite les
conditions concrètes d'une accumulation
de dett au-delà de ce seuil et est-ce
qu'on pourrait faire un point sur les
réflexions et discussions en cours sur
les différents scénarios envisageables
c'est-à-dire modification de
l'ordonnance de
1996 pour prévoir le transfert d'une
année de dette supplémentaire sans
changer l'échéance de 2033 parce que je
rappelle que c'est quand même le coup
près que voilà on a prévu l'extinction
de la dette en 2033 à la cadèe donc la
question se pose et puis la modification
par une loi organique de l'article 4 bis
de l'ordonnance de 1996 pour prévoir une
nouvelle échéance et permettre de
nouveaux transferts de dettes à la
cadess donc ça c'est le volet budgétaire
sur l'article 8 désormais comment les
travaux préparatoires à l' mission de la
déclaration sociale nominative de
substitution avance-il parce qu'on en a
beaucoup parlé les années passé et donc
pouvez-vous nous nous dire un petit peu
nous faire un petit point sur la
question et à quelle échéance devrait-il
aboutir à une solution pleinement
opérationnel parce que c'est c'est quand
même l'aboutissement d'une réflexion de
de
comment d'une attente aussi et et donc
quand verrons-nous le bout du tunnel la
usion d'une convention entre l'URSAF
caisse nationale la CCMSA et laag Carco
vous paraît-elle à même de garantir la
simplicité et la coordination des
procédures de contrôle des DSN et
d'émission des DSN de substitution je
vous remercie Mons direeur je vous
laisse répondre à notre
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
et je remercie madame la rapporteur Gén
finement d'avoir donné un peu ce
panorama des activités de Lurs c'est il
y a à la fois le côté
collecteur il y a aussi aussi bien
entendu la gestion de la trésorerie de
la sécurité sociale le reversement au
partenaire et puis aussi c'est
d'ailleurs présent dans certain nombre
d'articles des aussi un de services
développés par leursaf notamment par sur
le crédit impôt à la personne enfin
glement sur l'emploi à domicile alors
sur la question
effectivement de la
limite que on peut porter dans le cadre
d'une dette au sein de la cause c'est
une question qu'on se pose depuis un
certain nombre d'années et sur lequel je
pense qu'il y a pas de réponse uniforme
parce que ça dépend très
fortement la situation des marchés
financiers
dans dans le passé lorsqu avait été
faite d'importantes prises de dett la l
la grande crise financière de 2008-20 on
avait à l'époque approcher les 50
milliards de dettte àos et à l'époque on
s dit que c'était un peu la limite
physique acceptable bon
euh et après on était très an de ça et
puis
euh au moins la crise sanitaire on s'est
rendu compte que d'abord finalement sans
être à ce niveau-là on pouvait dans une
situation de blocage des marchés
financiers être extrêmement
fragilisé pour des raisons sur
lesquelles je vais revenir et puis à
partir du moment où la banque centrale a
injecté liquidité massivement finalement
on a dépassé très fortement ce qu'on
pensait de la limite inatteignable je
rappelle que au plus fort de la crise
sanitaire avant la reprise de dette cadè
la dette de la Cuse a atteint les 90
milliards donc selon la situation des
marchés financiers la réponse à cette
question va varier
alors on a deux contraintes on a une
contrainte forte du côté du financement
de la cause financement de la trésorerie
du régime général c'est qu'on a le droit
d'mettre que des titres à un an maximum
ça a deux conséquences c'est que d'une
part on est sur un marché de titres
financiers qui est plus limité vous avez
moins d'investisseurs qui achètent des
titres aussi courts que des titres de
dette plus longues et par ailleurs ça
nous oblige à aller tous les jours sur
les marché financier pour renouveler nos
émissions parce que quand on est sur des
titres courts ça veut dire que quasiment
tous les jours il y a des titres de
dette qui tombent donc il faut
rembourser et donc il faut retourner
quasiment tous les jours sur les marché
financiers pour couvrires nouveaux
titres et ça c'est une vraie différence
d'ailleurs entre ce que nous faisons et
ce que font nos amis collègues de de
l'Agence France Trésor qui va pas tous
les jours sur les marchés nous on doit
tous les jours réémettre pour couvrir
notre et renouveler en fait notre stock
de dette et du coup effectivement ça
nous rend particulièrement exposé à des
chocs qui pourraient survenir sur les
marchés financiers encore une fois c'est
quelque chose
qu'avant le
covid voyait un peu comme un sin noir
c'està dire bon c'est quelque chose qui
peut arriver en théorie mais dont on
pense que c'est improbable maintenant on
sait que c'est quelque chose qui peut
arriver sans avoirqu en crise sanitaire
on a pu voir l'an dernier dans le
contexte de remonttere des taux de crise
de l'énergie crise ukrainienne qui a eu
plusieurs mois pend lesquels les
investiseurs étaient très attentistes
donc globalement les marchés étaient un
peu inertes c'était plus difficile de de
trouver de trouver des des acquéreurs et
donc on était parfois un peu plus tendu
que on nait pas la situation de confort
qu'on qu'on souhaitait euh qu'on
souhaitait avoir alors pour rappel
d'ailleurs comment on a couvert les
choses pour la crise sanitaire c'est si
on fait un peu d'historique jusqu' en
2008 la COS avait un seul prêteur
historique qui était la craise des
dépôts avec la crise 2008 quand donc nos
besoins de financement ont explosé pour
atteindre les 50 milliards c'était bien
entendu très au-delà de ce que la Caisse
des Dépôts pouvait nous apporter donc
c'est là que nous sommes allé sur les
marchés et aujourd'hui le financement
par les marchés est archiominant c'està
dire qu'on est à 96 % de financement sur
les marchés financiers donc on émet des
titres
financiers au moment de la crise covid
on ne pouvait pas couvrir tous nos
besoins avec ces émissions de titre donc
ça veut dire qu'on a dû de nouveau
requérir recourir pardon à des prêts de
la caise des dépôts et par ailleurs un
prêt de poule bancaire c'estàdire qu'on
avait approché un certain nombre de
grands établissements pour nous prêter
jusqu'à 20 milliards donc ça veut dire
que dans une situation finalement comme
celle de 2000 2020 et malgré les mesure
exceptionnell pris par la Banque
centrale on avait dû franchement
accumuler différents modes de
financement pour pouvoir couvrir euh nos
besoins
et si euh parce que la question
effectivement qu'on pose est-ce que se
passe-il si on franchit cette limite
physique de ce qui peut être financé par
général alors il peut y avoir un impact
sur les coûts de financement parce que
plus on va être en difficulté pour
couvrir nos besoins de financement plus
on va devoir dégrader enfin plutôt
augmenter la rémunération mais pour moi
c'est pas le principal risque parce que
d'ailleurs en mars 2020 les marchés
financiers étaient fermés combien même
on aurait mis un un point de points 100
points de plus le risque c'est un moment
un risque de liquidité c'està-dire
est-ce que on est capable de couvrir ce
qu'on doit payer tous les jours voilà je
pense que
l'enjeu de maintenir un niveau de dette
raisonnable et qui ne fasse pas prendre
des risques
inconsidérés au
système c'est tout simplement de pouvoir
s'assurer que même s'il y a un choc
effectivement on pourra continuer à
payer les pensions le jour où il faut
les payer voilà ce qui était pour enfin
pour nous dans notre politique
c'est
l'élément jamais on a envisagé qu'on
pouvait agir là-dessus bien entendu
considère qu'on doit assurer ce paiement
des prestations au jour le jour quoi
qu'il arrive mais on a pu mesurer en
mars 2020 que dans sitation
de ce type ça n'est pas évident on a eu
quand même de TR semaines qui étaient
assez difficile et de ce fait par
rapport à la question que pe vous poser
ce qu'on voit c'est que avec la
trajectoire de déficit qui est prévu on
se retrouve en
2027 un niveau de dette de l'URSAF s'il
y a pas de reprise par la cadè d'ici là
qui finalement est assez proche de ce
qu'on a connu en 202021 mais sans crise
sanitaire
ça veut dire que notre capacité
éventuellement à encaisser un choc
d'ampleur covid on le souhaite pas mais
c'est pas non plus pas parti des
éléments complètement impossibles en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on doit intégrer
dans une gestion de
risque réduite je rappelle que en
2020 notre dette est passé de 30 à
milliard en 3 mois et donc ça veut dire
qu'effectivement avec cette trajectoire
de déficit et sans reprise
supplémentaire on se retrouve effecement
en 2027 dans une situation comparable à
celle de
202021 et ça veut dire que on est en
risque si se produit un événement
extrême comme le covid et bien entendu
j'ai pas mentionné les ala qui peuvent
aussi affecter le cadrage
macroéconomique
des de la trajectoire de déficit innexé
au pfss c'està dire si la croissance
effectivement est un peu moins bonne et
cetera bien entendu ça se verra
mécaniquement cette trajectoire donc
effectivement aujourd'hui une situation
qui est extrêmement confortable parce
que il y a eu cette reprise de dette
mais comme vous l'avez dit on arrive au
bout et on voit qu'on a déficit
important sur les 3 qu années qui
viennent donc la question qui se pose
c'est est-ce que
on on assume de
couvrir ces ces niveaux déficit là dans
le cadre d'une dette à cause ou est-ce
que on s'ppose des questions comme cell
que vous avz évoqué alors nous on n'a
pas été associé à ces travaux sur
des aménagements de l'ordonnance
organique sur la tête sociale donc je je
suis pas vraiment en mesure de vous de
vous répondre mais en tout cas
effectivement ça explique que ces
questions se posent
aujourd'hui alors votre autre question
porte effectivement sur la déclaration
sociale l'adminative de substitution
alors derrière ce thème technique et
barbare en fait se cache un enjeu très
important c'est tout simplement la
qualité des données des données de paye
que reçoivent les différents services
publics au premier handical de la
retraite mais pas seulement à partir du
desquels elle calcule il
calcule les prestations sociales
aujourd'hui vous avez un système
effectivement où on a une déclaration
sociale unique qui alimente aussi bien
sa pour son rôle de cotisation que les
cases de retraite et demain vocation
aussi à permettre au CAF par exemple de
verser de prestation dans le cas du
versement à la
source un des enjeux c'est de s'assurer
que lorsque côté yoursaf on détecte des
anomalies des erreurs des
incohérences sur ces données voire
lorsque on fait des contrôles sur place
dans une entreprise et qu'on déte qu'on
redresse que ces erreurs enfin ces
corrections plutôt soient bien véhiculé
à l'ensemble des destinataire des
déclarations sociales avec un premier
enjeu très fort qui est le
rétablissement des droits du côté de la
retraite donc effectivement c'est pour
cela que a été inscrit ce projet de
déclaration sociale de substitution qui
prévoit que donc lorsque on détecte une
anomalie dans une erreur une incohérence
dans les déclarations d'un
employeur lorsqu'on fait euh un
redressement pour s'assurer que
l'ensemble des partenaires concerné
puissent en tier les conséquences sur le
calcul des prestations donc on adressera
c'estàd que l'URSAF ou la MSA pour le
régimricle adressera une déclaration qui
permettra de corriger et donc de
garantir que par exemple notamment du
côté de de la knave on peut bien tirer
les conséquences de ces corrections
alors c'est un chantier que nous avons
lancé il y a deux deux composantes dans
ce chantier selon que la la correction
par l'URSAF euh fait suite à un contrôle
au sens du contrôle URSAF sur place ou
sur pièce euh ou qu'elle fait suite à la
détection
d'anomalie par des traitements
automatisés au moment de la
déclaration dans le cadre de ce qui les
corrections à l'issue des contrôles nous
nous travaillons pour être capable
d'envoyer ses données en 2024 au CA de
retraite alors après c'est un projet
partenarial donc pour
pouvoir pour que ce flux puisse bien se
passer il faut que les les récepteurs
soient bien alignés sur le calendrier
tout simplement il y a pas de tout façon
C dans la loi il y a pas de divergence
de fond mais par contre c'est souvent
compliqué de rabouter les calendriers et
pour ce qui concerne les corrections
issuesà des contrôles automatisés qu'on
fait au moment de la déclaration là on
prévoit une mise en place en 2025 mais
c'est quand même un très grand progrès
dans la manière dont on pourra garantir
que les anomalies erreurs de paye ou
noncformité dans le cadre des contrô
voir si son travil disimulés permettront
pourront être corrigés pour le calcul de
la retraite et sachant que l'étape
ultérieur qu'on peut imaginer c'est par
exemple aussi qu'on puisse en tirer les
conséquences du côté des prestations
prestation CAF alors concernant la
convention que vous évoquez entre
URSAF MSA et AG
Carco alors à l'origine il y avait une
convention qui av été prévu dans le
casadre de la mise en place de
l'allègement général étendu c'està dire
que lorsqueen
2019 on a eu des allègements de
cotisation qui ont porté pour la
première fois pas seulement sur la parti
URSAF mais aussi le parti agir Carco on
s'est rendu compte qu'il fallait pouvoir
apporter des réponses homogènes uniforme
aux questions les entreprises poseraient
sur l'application de C législation parce
qu'il s'agit bien commme d'avoir une
même compréhension selon que le même
allègement porte sur la partie URSAF ou
la partie ager
Carco donc là en fait ces dispositions
elles pte sur un champ qui est plus
large c'està-dire que on voit bien que
aujourd'hui quand on
va corriger des données sur sur les
données sociales mais aussi dire quand
les entreprises vont nous poser des
questions sur l'assiette par exemple de
cotisation ça a des conséquences à la
fois côté URSAF et côté j Carco donc ça
suppose effectivement qu'on ait une
coordination assez forte sur les
réponses àortter donc là les travaux ils
sont je dirais en train d'être relancés
et effectivement un enjeu important
c'est d'avoir un dispositif qui soit à
la fois réactif
euh qui en même temps engage les
différents
partenaires et qui soit lisible pour
pour l'entreprise or voilà dès qu'on
doit faire travailler plusieurs réseaux
dans ce sens on sait que c'est pas
impossible mais c'est en tout cas plus
exigeant et donc clairement les travaux
enfin c'est un travail qui est en cours
qui est en cours de de
définition merci Monsieur le Directeur
je vais donner la parole maintenant à
Pascal
gruni merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur alors moi c'est
sont des questions surarticle 9 euh donc
sur le nouveau schéma de financement des
régimes spéciaux fermés donc en 2023 et
proposé par le gouvernement ça fait
peser sur le régime général la charge
d'équilibrer les 10 régimes en
contrepartie notamment du versement par
l'état d'une somme qui correspond au
crédit actuel de la mission régimes
sociaux et retraite et ce que je voulais
savoir c'est s'il y avait si il y aura
des conséquences pour l'ursave caisse
nationale au titre de sa mission de
gestion de la trésorerie du régime
général et aussi si elle est en mesure
de de les assumer et ensuite sur la
réforme de l'assiette sociale des
travailleurs indépendants est-ce que
vous pouvez présenter le mode de calcul
de l'assiette de CG et de l'assiette de
cotisation sociale des travailleurs
indépendant ses conséquences sur les
droits sociaux acquis par ses assurés et
est-ce que la refondte de ces de ces
assiettes qui est envisagé par le
gouvernement semble pouvoir se heurter à
des difficultés d'ordre pratique
merci très bien la parole à Corina
Bert merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur deux petites
questions à quelle hauteur
enfin en 2024 donc pour la construction
du budget de la Sécurité sociale se
situe le le niveau des cotisations
sociales parce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
dans la construction du budget nous
avons une part de TVA de plus en plus
importante donc quelle est la part dans
ce budget des cotisations sociales et
puis une question de la part d'Al Milon
qui était obligé de de s'absenter qui
voulait savoir ce que vous pensiez de la
la CRDS la contribution de remboursement
de la dette sociale qui avait été créée
en en 1996 de mémoire et qui devait
s'éteindre avec la cadesse en 2009 voilà
euh donc on dit voilà c'est un impôt qui
je crois s'applique sur la plupart des
revenus si passe cette CRDS quels
seraient les
impacts ensuite Olivier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur merci pour la clarté de vos
propos vous nous avez expliqué la
dépendance de la cosse au marché
financier j'ai entendu plus de 80 % sont
financés ainsi alors qu'autrefois
c'était par la Caisse des Dépôts avant
la crise financière de 2008 ma question
est la suivante suante est-ce que vous
êtes étroitement dépendant de la qualité
de la signature de la France ou est-ce
que au fond vous avez une marge
d'autonomie c'est-à-dire que si demain
il y avait une dégradation de la note
est-ce que ça touche aussi les taux
d'intérêt de de des emprunts faits par
la C je vous remercie monsieur directeur
je propose de répondre à ces trois
intervenants et après Onra une série de
questions merci monsieur le Président
alors
concernant de questions deame lace alors
sur la la la réforme du cinéma
financement des des systèmes de
retraite on est dans un dispositif qui à
voocation être précisé dans le cadre de
du projet loi de finance pour 2025 donc
pour l'instant on n pas forcément tous
les éléments permettant de répondre aux
questions que que vous posez à juste
titre ce que je peux dire c'est que en
tout cas il y a dans ce qui a pu être
exposé pour le moment y compris dans le
cadre du pfss et puis ça sera un point
de vigilance très fort aussi pour les
partenaires sociaux effectivement un
enjeu de neutralité financière pour les
générale c'està dire que si par exemple
ça a un impact sur les le profil de
trésorerie parce que effectivement on
peut avoir des versements des
décaissements qui arrivent à des moments
différents ça vocation effectivement à
être neutralisé dans les relation
financière entre l'État et la sécurité
sociale sur la capacité def à le prendre
en charge oui parce que ce n'est pas non
plus des enjeux
financier majeur au regard de de de ce
que porte le régime général donc il y a
pas de difficultés techniquees par
doncquement il y AA un point de
vigilance politique sur la question de
la neutralité financière pour le régime
général alors sur l'assiette des travers
indépendants alors le sujet a été exposé
de manière beaucoup plus précise dans le
rapport du Conseil du financement de la
protection sociale alors la situation
est la suivante l'assiette de la CSG et
d'ailleurs de la CRDS des travailleurs
indépendant qui donc ne leur cré pas de
droits sociaux
et calculer sur ce ce qu'on appelle
l'assiette brute le revenu brut des
trava indépendants alors que les
cotisations
sociales qui ell donc son créatrice de
droit notamment à la retraite mais aussi
invalidité ouité journalière sont
calculés sur une assiette nette assiette
net des cotisations alors ça pose un
certain nombre de difficultés alors la
première c'est que lorsque notamment la
CSG a été
créé lorsque aussi les textes ont évolué
sur les indépendant
on a considéré qu'on prenait l'assiette
net l'assiette brute en faisant des
comparaisons a les salariés qui
n'étaient pas pertinentes parce que
l'assiette brute un travailleur
indépendant comme pour un
travailleurépendant il a pas de
différence la cotisation salariale la
cotisation patronale il y a que la
cotisation personnelle travailleur
indépendant ce qu'on appelle l'assiette
brute pour un indépendant c'est ce
qu'on appellerait pour un salarié le
super brut donc ça veut dire que les
travaille indépendants payent la CG CRDS
sur effecement une
assiette très majoré et ça qui ère des
droits sur une assiette nette là où le
salarié lui çaquère des droits retraite
par exemple sur son assiette brute donc
c'est pour ça que au conseil de
financement de la protection sociale
avait mis ce sujet en évidence en
montrant que toute chose égal par
ailleurs on avait effectivement un
système qui était plutôt pénalisant pour
l'acquisition de droits contributifs par
les travailleurs indépendants
euh à la fois parce que l'assiette sur
laquelle il se constitue droits est plus
faible et parce que au sein de
l'ensemble de prélévements sociaux la
partie qui leur crée pas de droit est
finalement majoré par rapport à la
partie qui leur crée des droits donc
c'est ce qui a conduit depuis plusurs
années à avoir cette réflexion sur une
évolution l'assiette sociale des travers
indépendant qui viserait à calculer
l'assiette sur laquelle se constituent
des
droits non pas avec ce système où en
plus il faut déduire les cotisations
de du montant sur lequ sont calculés ce
qui a un calcul comme très compliqué qui
fait qui pourit effet comme qu'un
certain nombre de trava indépendant voir
parfois d'expert comptabl font des
erreurs dans ce qu'il déclare parce que
c'est quand même enfin expliquer que on
qu'on déduit les cotisations sociales
de de l'assiette ENF pour savoir comment
calculer les cotisation soci faut les
déduire ça c'est un calcul circulaire
donc voilà avir un certain niveau
mathématique pour y arriver donc c'est
déjà ça POS déjà des vrais problèmes de
lisibilité pour les travailleurs
indépendants ça veut dire que ça
explique aussi qu'on soit pas en mesure
de dire de manière claire quel est le
niveau de préléments sociaux pour un
travailleur indépendant donné et puis
par ailleurs il a cet enjeu
effectivement d'équilibre dans l'effort
contributif donc il y a des réflexions
effecement qui ont ét engagés plusieurs
années pour passer à une assiette je
dirais unifié
entre CG et cotisation sociale qui sera
en fait calculé par rapport on dire au
revenu brut sur lequel on applique un
abattement
mais l'idée étant de relever l'assiette
sur laquelle les travailleurs
indépendants se constituent des droits
donc pour améliorer les droits contribut
travill indépendant dans un contexte où
on le sait le niveau de retraite des
artisans commerçants est assez minime
alors à la fois du fait ce sujet
d'assiette du fait aussi que on a une
population quand même qui est pour
partie a des revenus faibles que aussi
du côté le régime d' travailleurs
indépendant il n'y a pas la garantie de
la trimestre par an c'estàdire que si on
a un revenu qui est trop faible on on ne
valide que trois trimestres VO quand on
est autoentrepreneur on a aucune
garantie de valider un trimestre on a
des revenus trop faiblees donc voilà la
réflexion
effectivement qui a été engagé il y a un
certain temps c'est de passer une
assiette unifié qui je dirais à
prélèvement global permet d'avoir
davantage de prélèvements sociaux qui
créer des droits pour les travailleurs
indépendants donc d'améliorer les droits
pour les travailleurs indépendants alors
après ça pose des questions bien entendu
vu bah de bouclag financier d'impact
redistributif dans un contexte où
euh autant pour les artisans commerçant
on a une population qui a un seul les
mêmes règles il y a aussi les poations
libérales qui sont concerné avec 10
caises de profession libéral qui ont
chacune leur règle et donc c'est plus
compliqué effectivement à modéliser et à
prendre en compte les impacts sur ces
différentes professions alors vous avez
posé la question des difficultés euh
opérationnelles ça pourrait poser pour
nous c'est pas forcément des difficultés
par contre très clairement ça suppose de
réinterroger le parcours de déclaration
de revenus travailleur indépendant qui
est aujourd'hui partagé entre leursf et
c'est plutôt que nous on s'appuie sur la
déclaration de revenu auprès des impôts
pour avoir le revenu trava indépendant
et aujourd'hui on a un parcours
d'ailleurs il y a à la fois la
déclaration professionnelle l'
professionnelle la dé attend de revenu
personnel ça c'est un parcours qui
existe aujourd'hui et qu'il faudrait
probablement un peu rebattre dans ce cas
donc c'est pas un obstacle c'est pas
insurmontable c'est par contre
effectivement un accompagnement assez
fort parce que ça peut impliquer des
changements dans les habitudes des
travaills indépendants ou de leurs
experts comptables en terme de
déclaration alors j' viens maintenant
aux questions de de Madame madame
Humbert alors je n'ai pas
malheureusement en tête le dernier
chiffre sur la part des coisations
je en têre
que le sujet est à peu près stable
depuis les dernières basculle de
cotisation qui ont pu avoir c'estàd
notamment la mise en place d'allègement
général étendu avait quand même la
conversion fait du CIC en allègement
général avait comme réduit significative
niveau des cotisations et depuis il y a
pas eu non plus de grand mouvement
sur la composition du financement
sociale globalement on reste quand même
sur un financement majorit par
cotisation de mémoire à hauteur de 70 %
alors après de manière très différenciée
selon les
branches quasiment à 100% sur la branche
de travail très fortement aussi sur la
branche vieillesse même si nos
ressources fiscales qui sont venus et
par contre on est un peu en de de 50 %
je crois sur la branche maladie ou la
branche la branche famille alors
concernant la question posée sur la CRDS
je pense qu'on peut pas regarder la
question la CRDS indépendamment de
l'ensemble de l'équilibre qu'il y a dans
la loi organique sur les loi de
financement sociale
sur l'autorisation ENF l'encadrement du
déficit de la Sécurité
sociale l'encadrement de la dette du
régime général et le système de reprise
de dette par la cadè parce que si je
refais la théorie initiale thorie
initiale c'est que la S sociale est
censé être à moyen terme en tout cas à
l'équilibre
donc n pas censé constituer de dettes
pement Besin de trésorerie parce que des
bonnes mauvaises années mais on est pas
censé accumuler la dette péren il y a eu
différents événements économiques crise
de 93 crise de 2008 qui ont conduit à
qu'àun moment on accumule des et à
chaque fois le principe qui était
notamment la loi organique de 96 c'était
de cantonner C dette sociale c'estàdire
qu' considérit que c'était quelque chose
d'exceptionnel qui nait pas vocation à
se répéter et c'est pour cela que donc
on faisait porter on le fait toujours
porter d'ailleurs par un organisme
spécifique la cadè et avec une
contribution spécifique la CDS même si
après de la CADs a été complété d'autres
ressources notamment de
CSG et avec l'idée que finalement VI y
avoir une forme de contrainte mise sur
le système et notamment sur les choix
politiques fait sur le niveau déficite
c'està-dire que si on laisse l'dficit de
laass filé à un moment ça se retrouve a
dans un niveau de dette sur du régime
général qui fait qu'on
devra faire une repise de det par la
CADs et donc allonger la durée de vie de
la CRDS et donc finalement ça coûte
politiquement c'est un peu ça la logique
générale alors après je pense que du
coup on peut pas se prononcer sur que
ferait-on si pas la CRDS bon d'ailleurs
on voit qu'on a recouru à d'autres
recettes pour
financer pour financer la cadesse mais
je pense que c'est vraiment très lié à
cette construction politique
intellectuelle qui vise à apporter un de
de règles d'or ou de garde-fou sur
l'accumulation de déficit à la sécurité
sociale j' maintenant la question
fiement posée par monsur sénateur
olivieron alors oui effectivement nous
sommes enfin nous sommes notés par les
agences de notation nous aussi et nous
sommes effectivement arrimés à la note
de la France alors particularité c'est
que les notes dont on parle le plus
agence de notation sont des notes sur la
dette à long terme nous comme on a une
dette de court terme euh il y a on a une
note qui est apprécié différemment mais
qui est quand même fortement corrélée à
la à la note de l'État français sur sur
la de long terme et oui effectivement
s'il y avait une dégradation de la note
de la France on le verrait immédiatement
dans nos
prix très bien je vais donner la parole
maintenant à cier
poropoui merci Monsieur le Directeur
bonjour vous vous souvenez certainement
que nous avions fait un rapport avec
Monsieur Savari euh sur l'unification du
recouvrement donc social avec un bilan
qui nous était apparu évidemment
contrasté
hein puisque il y avait nous avions
pointé le fait qu'il y avait des
perspectives sécurisé au-delà du fait
que nous pensions que laag Carco
euh perdrait son rôle de point de
contact avec les entreprises il y avait
un autre souci que nous mettions en av
avant c'est que laagir Carco fiabilise
les données DSN à la maille individuelle
euh pour votre cas ce n'était pas ce
n'était pas votre cas et nous avions
constaté que ça nous posait problème
donc ce transfert puisque vous n'étiez
pas engagé assez fortement de notre
point de vue sur la collecte de données
à la maille individuelle alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous puisque vous
vous faisiez à l'époque euh je pense des
expérimentations euh sur deux caisses il
me semble hein vous aviez engagé des euh
ben en fin de compte voilà est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus est-ce que
vous avez avancer
sur ce sujet je vous remercie alors
maintenant la parole à Madame
ashliman merci monsieur le Président
euh Monsieur le Directeur
à l'issue de la crise covid il y a eu
une pause sur le recouvrement d'un
certain nombre de prélèvements sociaux
qui a duré un certain nombre de temps il
était prévu que la reprise de ces
opérations de recouvrement reprennent en
2023 j'ai plusieurs questions qui sont
liées à cette
situation d'abord savoir si il y a des
situations différenciées selon les
régions don la le contexte
socio-économique peut-être différencié
euh savoir également ce que si on ne
comment vous envisagez cette reprise
dans la mesure où il y a aussi un
télescopage avec une situation
conjoncturelle un peu compliquée qui
peut être liée à l'arrivée à maturité
d'un certain nombre de remboursement de
PGE notamment mais aussi la fin des
aides lié au quoi au quoi qu'il en coûte
et enfin
également à la recrudescence des
faillites qu'on observe dans un certain
nombre de régions je pense notamment à
l'île-de-fance comment vous envisagez
donc les opérations de recouvrement à la
fois amiaable et forcé que vous allez
être obligé d'opérer
prochainement merci et enfin Frédéric
puissard merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Directeur juste
revenir Monsieur le Directeur sur
l'article 6 qui concerne les plateformes
de de mise en relation avec deux
mécanismes qui sont introduits dans ce
PLFSS un mécanisme qui pour moi est plus
un mécanisme de contrôle et l'autre
peut-être plus un mécanisme de
simplification est-ce que vous pouvez
très rapidement nous les
présentereur pardon euh concernant
effectivement la question centrale hein
posé par la sénatrice madame cainaopouli
sur la question de laaffilation des
données sociales
ce sujet il est très lié d'ailleurs à ce
que j'ai tout à l'heure sur la
déclaration sociale de substitution
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est que on établit
un centre de prestation d'abord la
retraite mais demain avec le versement à
la source davantage prestation comme la
d'activité le RSA les allocations
logement c'est déjà le cas à partir des
données sociales de paye et donc ce qui
met du coup un accent important sur la
qualité de ces données sociales de paye
on sait aujourd'hui qu'il y a euh jeais
sur la première paye faite sur un mois
donné un certain nombre d'anomalies qui
rvoi en général les problèmes de
paramétrage l'iciel de paie
euh nous on opère depuis longtemps quoi
qu'il pu dire laager Carco des contrôles
y compris à c'està dire à l'échelle du
salarié pour identifier un nom
d'anomalie on a au cours de l'année 2022
déployé des contrôles automatisés qui
permet de détecter des
incohérences y compris encore une fois
he à l'échelle du salarié sur ces
données sociales et en ce moment euh
nous contribuons aussi sur par exemple
ce qu'on appelle la mise en place du
montant net social montant net social
qui donc est utilisé pour calculer RSA
Prim une
activité qui depuis le mois de juillet
figure sur le buletin de salaire des
salariés euh qui euh peut désormais être
déclaré par l'employeur sachant qu'il va
être obligatoirement déclaré pardon par
l'employeur à partir de janvier et là
donc nous nous intervenons effectivement
pour faire des contrôles de cohérence
sur comp social c'està-dire vérifier
pour les différents salariés que il n'y
a pas d'incohérence entre ce que
l'employeur a calculé comme montant aide
social
et et les autres données de paye dont on
dispose donc oui on est on est en train
de développer on a dévelop on a déjà
mise en production ces contrôle sur les
données sociales individuelles et sa
vocation à se développer notamment dans
le cadre d'une gouvernance de la donnée
sociale qui s'est mise en place cette
année de quoi s'agit-il concrètement
donc vous avez auprès de la direction
sociale une mission interministérielle
sur les données social qui vise
justement à mettre en place un programme
de contrôle de la qualité des données
sociales très concrètement on a des
organismes qui reçoivent les données
sociales et qui du coup sont demandeurs
de contrôle de vérification sur ces
données sociales déclarées et nous on a
pour responsabilité bah de mettre en
place les contrôles automatisés très
concrètement que ça donne ça veut dire
qu'on va chaque mois désormais on fait
ses contrôles automatisés sur les
données sociales s'il y a des anomalies
on fait un signalement un retour vers
l'employeur on l'invite à corriger
et d'abord on va un processus on va
l'inviter à corriger et puis
effectivement 202425 s'il na pas corrigé
lui-même on pourra corriger sa place
donc effectivement on est bien dans
cette démarche de fablation des données
sociales concernant effectivement les
questions de reprise de recouvrement en
sortie de crise alors c'est un mouvement
même qu'on a amorcé
dès la rentrée septembre 2022 avec une
approche qui a visé à avoir la phase
amiable la plus la plus longue
possible et à donner le plus
d'information possible et le plus de
chance poss possible aux entreprises qui
à un moment ne respectent pas leur
échéancier de
revenir sur justement un paiement
régulier et un nouvel échérencier je
rappelle que ça fait ça fait suite à un
processus complètement exceptionnel
qu'on a mis en place pendant la crise
qui a consisté à ce que l'URSAF propose
et metett en place d'elle-même des
échanciers des plans d'appurement pour
les entreprises et travaillant
indépendant débiteur c'estàdire 1006
travailleurs indépendants et 700000
employeurs qui ont reçu ce plan
d'appurement de la part de l'Ursa et
dispositif qui fonctionne très bien
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui 80 % de ces
plans d'apppurement sont
respectés euh la dette accumulée par les
employeurs travaillant indépendant entre
mars 2020 et fin 2021 c'était 22
milliards fin 2021 aujourd'hui on a
moins de 8 parce que ça ça s'est
remboursé aujourd'hui on a moins de 8
milliards moins de 8 versus 2 22 fin
2000 2021 donc on voit que ce dispositif
marche et qu'il est bien respecté alors
effectivement après on a des entreprises
qui parfois ont pu ne pas respecter leur
plan ont pu ne pas payer les C courantes
donc là on a eu des phases encore une
fois d'information on a d'abord envoyé
des relevés de dett pour le indiquer ce
qu'elle devaiit encore àur SAF et ça
permettait éventuellement de les les
inviter à revenir vers nous pour
conclure un plan plan un nouveau nouvel
échéancier éventuellement fiabiliser
cette dette si avit un débat un
désaccord avec nous sur le sujet après
on a fait donc des relances amiables et
à chaque fois en donnant plus de temps
au entreprises pour réagir que dans les
parcours de recouvrement qu'on avait
avant la
crise aujourd'hui i ce processus il est
pas encore tout à fait achevé au sens où
aujourd'hui par exemple les contraintes
ont repris vis-à-vis des donc la
contrainte délivré par bissier vis-à-vis
des débiteurs en tout cas dans le cas
général puectivement il y a des
situation de différenciation
euh ces contraintes on les a précédé
encore une fois de derniers avis avant
poursite et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que sur l'ensemble de ces phases de
relance à chaque fois tu as permis de
ramener une partie des débiteurs sur la
conclusion euh déchéancier mais
aujourd'hui par exemple on n'a pas
encore repris les assignations en
produre Collectiv au niveau de ce qu'on
réalisait euh avant la crise alors pour
répondre à la question effectivement
d'abord de la différenciation
territoriale oui effectivement on a eu
notamment des calendriers différents
dans les départements d'outr mer d'une
part parce que la crise sanitaire a duré
plus longtemps parce que par ailleurs on
avait des situations de fragilité
préexistantes qui étaient plus forte
donc on a eu un calendrier encore plus
espacé et aujourd'hui même entre les
différents départements d'R m on a des
différenciations de calendrier parce que
la situation de sensibilité n'est pas la
même on a par sitation qui est assez
complexe en Guadeloupe et sur laquelle
on se donne un peu plus de temps vu la
masse de
d'entreprises débitrice mais encore une
fois chaque fois cette idée que on
multiplie les relances les procédures
qui sont l'occasion pour l'entreprise de
revenir vers nous pour conclure un
échancier et même quand on Enie la
contrainte par vicier si l'entreprise
revient vers luici ou vers nous en
propose en essayant de négocier un plan
c'est crédible on accepte et on privilie
cette démarche cette démarche
amiable alors sur la question d'ailleurs
des défaillance effectivement on a un
niveau de procédure collective qui est
remonté par rapport à ce qu'on avait en
202021 mais c'est par 2021 on avait eu
une division par deux ou trois du nombre
Collectiv aujourd'hui on est à peu près
près au niveau qu'on avait en
2019 ce qui est plutôt rassurant avac
quand même cette réserve que précisément
LF n'a pas encore repris son volume
normal d'activité sur ce sujet et donc
ça veut dire qu'il y a quand on aura
fini complètement la la reprise du
recouvrement effectivement ça peut se
traduire par un surcroix en tout cas une
progression supplémentaire du nombre de
de procédure collective alors comment on
prend en compte les situations de
fragilité qui peuvent exister
tout simplement on a su faire la preuve
je crois depuis la fin de la crise
sanitaire que on savait remettre en
place des mesures d'accompagnement
exceptionnel lorsqu'il y avait des
événements singuliers qui justifiaent
l'été dernier enfin l'été 2022 pardon
avec les incendies qui ont pu affecter
un de territoire là on a surmettre des
procédur processus d'étalement de
renégociation d'échéanciers on l'a fait
aussi pour les touchés par la crise
énergétique on l' a fait au enfin cet
été avec les émeutes et on va le refaire
par exemple en Guadeloupe avec l'ouragan
qui vient fraper ce ce territoire le le
weekend dernier donc voilà on maintient
cette capacité à remettre de la
souplesse sur des événements singuliers
qui affectent certains certains secteurs
bien entendu si on a des situations qui
font qu' entr un moment nous vient vers
nous pour
euh demander à une rét chencier c'est
quelque chose qu'on regarde avec
bienveillance parce qu'encore une fois
on préfère toujours euh avoir un
échancier pourant qu'il soit crédiible
euh que bien entendu d'envoyer euh
entrise au tapis et après nous
aujourd'hui on a plutôt des éléments
assez rassurants sur la capacité des
entreprises d' payer leurs cotisation
parce que déjà comme je vous dis sur la
dette covid finalement
elle est remboursée de manière très euh
respectueuse scrupuleuse par la plupart
des entreprise et sur les échéances
courantes on a retrouvé euh ces derniers
mois le niveau d'impayé qu'on avait en
2019 alors même qu'on n pas encore
repris toutes les procédures cersitives
donc c'est plutôt
rassurant au niveau macro parce qu'après
bien entendu ce sont les secteurs
sitation très différentes hein j'
concient mais au niveau macro c'est
plutôt rassurant sur la capacité alors à
fois sur le civisme des employeurs mais
aussi sur leur capacité à
euh honorer leurs engagements leurs
obligations obligations
sociales
ah excusez-moi
ouiou oui oui oui suis vraiment je
vraiment désolé alors oui effectivement
il y a comme c'était ma fait suivante je
j'avais perdu de vue je suis d'AC mes
excuses alors effectivement cet article
met en place en fait un précompte des
cotisations sociales pour les activités
réalisées par les microprpreneurs sur
les plateformes alors ça fait suite à un
constat qu'on a réalisé depuis quelques
années d'une sous-déclaration très
importante de la part des
micro-entrepreneurs des plateformes on a
pu faire ces évaluations tout simplement
parce que depuis quelques années les
plateformes sont tenu déc déclarer à DG
FIP qui nous transm ces données les
chiffres d'affaires par les
micro-entrepreneurs et et donc on a
comparlant des deux on voit qu' une s
déclaration assez importante qu'on avait
chiffré quelques années à 140 millions
c'estut-êt un minorant du fait des
méthodes retenues c'estement plus et par
ailleurs comme c'est une activité qui se
développe ça a certainement augmenté
depuis et donc le dispositif euh comme
vous l'avez comme vous l'avez dit il a à
la
fois dirais un aspect de simplification
pour le micro-entrepreneur qui n'a plus
finalement à assurer lui-même la prise
en charge de ses déclarations et la
gestion du paiement c'estàd qu'il est
plus obligé de retenir sur ce que lui
reverse la plateforme ce qu'il devra
reverser leursaf et aussi effectivement
un élément de sécurisation des montants
déclarés et des montants payés puisque
c'est la plateforme qui est responsable
du reversement donc c'est à la fois
effectivement une mesure de lutte contre
la fraude très clairement c'est une
mesure de simplification et de
facilitation de la vie de
micro-entrepreneurs concernés et c'est
aussi une mesure qui sécurise les droits
sociaux c'est c'est les travailleurs
parce que on sait que on a affaire à
microentrepreneurs qui pour certains je
pense déclarait pas forcément tout parce
que la question de leur droit à retraite
leur paraissait extrêmement éloigné ou
théorique ou abstraite et bien entendu
euh ce précomte permet de garantir qu'il
se constiue bien des droits à retraite
en en regarde avec leur
activité Monsieur le Directeur un grand
merci pour ses explications et ces
précisions c'est toujours très technique
hein voilà c'est vrai que pour ceux qui
arrivent il y a besoin un peu de de de
temps pour rentrer dans les sujets un
grand merci je vous rappelle les uns les
autres qu'on se retrouve demain demain
10h30 pour le audition du ministre
Rousseau de la santé c'est sal
clémenau demain sal
clémenauh voilà merci beaucoup et on se
retrouve dans l'miss cet
après-midi
merci